[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un repaso por las noticias
más destacadas relacionadas con la
pandemia del cob y 19 en nuestro
continente a continuación algunos de los
temas que vamos a tratar en este
programa algunos de ellos
esta semana eeuu alivio algunas de las
restricciones de viajes también abrió
sus fronteras y permitió el ingreso de
viajeros particularmente procedentes de
europa que tenían algunas restricciones
esta apertura tiene lugar cuando eeuu
también presenta una lenta tasa de
vacunación que alcanza sólo el 58 por
ciento de la población con el esquema
completo hablaremos de cuba' la isla
caribeña que está registrando una
reducción considerable en el número de
casos de contagio a medida que la
vacunación es cada vez más rápida y
abarca más sectores de la sociedad
cubana este país ya abrió las fronteras
para la llegada de turistas y también
habilitó las escuelas para diferentes
grupos de la sociedad esto a medida que
avanza la inoculación masiva en los
adolescentes y ahora también en los
menores de edad y hablaremos del
continente europeo que es ahora el foco
de la pandemia según lo ha dicho la o ms
alemania el reino unido rusia austria
entre otros países son los que están
presentando las mayores cifras las
cifras más preocupantes e incluso
récords
los expertos indican que en su mayoría
son personas que han tomado la decisión
de no vacunarse y están más expuestas al
virus particularmente a la variante
delta que cada vez se está convirtiendo
en una variante más contagiosa pues
vamos a comenzar y lo vamos a hacer
entonces con las cifras vamos a
actualizar no saber cómo está el cierre
de la semana algunos países de nuestra
región han presentado aumentos ya lo
decíamos el cierre de esta semana canadá
ya registra 17 millones de casos
confirmados los fallecidos superan allí
los 29 mil o más de los 29 mil en méxico
hay 38 casos confirma 38 millones de
casos confirmados las víctimas mortales
superan las 290 mil en ecuador hay más
de 500 19.000 casos registrados y los
fallecidos ya superan los 32 mil vamos a
bolivia en donde esta semana finalizan
con más de 500 21.000 casos registrados
y los fallecidos ya superan los 18 mil
para terminar veamos cifras de uruguay
en donde hay más de 395 mil casos
registrados y los fallecidos superan los
y vamos a conversar con el doctor carlos
eduardo pérez médico infectólogo y
también asesor científico de france 24
ya está con nosotros para nuestra
habitual consulta doctor pérez
bienvenido como siempre un gusto estar
con usted acá para conversar y para
aclarar muchas dudas que tenemos por
parte de los televidentes hablemos de la
tolerancia cero' mientras vemos que
algunos países intentan convivir con el
virus reabrir la economía
puede abrir ya la actividad social
prácticamente al completo algunos países
como china están con esta política de
tolerancia cero en donde acompañan una
alta eba con una alta tasa de vacunación
con
confinamientos a pesar de que se están
presentando pocos casos en algunas
ciudades como mirar estas dos opciones
como los de usted
si digamos que es una cosa importante es
entender en qué fase o cómo se comporta
el vino y la eliminación se logra con
estas estrategias por ejemplo de cierres
confinamientos pero el gran problema es
que las vacunas logran evitar la
enfermedad grave pero no cortar la
cadena de transmisión por eso la mayoría
de países que entraron en esa fase de
eliminación como fue en australia nueva
zelandia convirtieron a una estrategia
de mitigación es decir de controlar los
enfermos que tienen en china pues te
unas características por su sistema de
gobierno al hacerlo de este tipo de
confinamiento pero definitivamente
nosotros debemos aprender a vivir con el
virus no cerrar las fronteras eso es un
error y aumentar las tasas de vacunación
y buscar y reformular vacunas que corten
la cadena de transmisión doctor hablemos
de esa investigación que realizó la
universidad queen mary en el reino
unido- que encontró las causas que
predisponen a la enfermedad del cobi 19
que podrían evitarse en algunos
pacientes de qué estamos hablando
ya entendimos que el coi 19 afecta a las
personas que tienen comorbilidades
diabetes hipertensión obesidad etcétera
pero esto se ha encontrado dos
determinantes muy importantes uno la
baja y el bajo ejercicio físico la
disminución de la actividad física y
también digamos algo que condiciona las
enfermedades y las comorbilidades
están adecuadas con la mala nutrición
con con problemas que tienen que ver con
la alimentación entonces estas
combinaciones del mal cuidado de la
enfermedad crónica la disminución de la
actividad física sumadas a factores que
aumentan los riesgos de las
comorbilidades pues incrementan el
riesgo de que las personas adquieran el
coi y se compliquen por él por eso es
tan importante priorizar las vacunas en
los grupos que tienen enfermedades
crónicas y sobre todo en personas que
tienen poca actividad física y que
tienen como habilidades
doctor pérez le cambió completamente de
tema hablemos ahora de las vacunas que
son desarrolladas o que fueron
desarrolladas en la isla de cuba estas
vacunas todavía no tienen una aprobación
oficial por parte de la ms como esa este
proceso de aprobación y qué pasa con los
países que ya han comprado estas vacunas
que tienen aprobación a que se están
exponiendo
santiago es muy importante recordar que
el leche que se han hecho con hace un
poco tiempo no quiere decir que no se
hayan cumplido todos los parámetros que
deben hacer y para eso hay estudios fase
1 fase 2 fase 3 fase 3b fase 4 y lo que
pasa con las vacunas por ejemplo la
iniciativa cubana es que no conocemos
los estudios de espacio 333 de fase 3
son estudios que además de ser segura
muestran eficacia
en la población y uno puede evaluar los
resultados y confrontar al no tener esos
estudios pues no se puede someter a las
entidades regulatorias y si los tienen y
los no son contundentes pues no se hace
la aprobación por la entidad regulatoria
cada país compra las vacunas pero de su
instituto regulatorio y en dos países de
américa latina está muy fortalecido
verificar cuál es la información que
aporta esa vacuna para poderla aprobar
usar en su población en este momento la
información que tenemos una información
solamente local y estamos esperando pues
la información completa para poderle
evaluar y tener otras vacunas más
necesitamos pero necesitamos también que
sean seguras eficaces y que tengan los
estudios clínicos
doctor y esta semana finalizó en la
ciudad de glasgow en escocia la cumbre
de la cob 26 allí hubo muchas propuestas
por parte de los mandatarios muchas
promesas también pero fue poco lo que se
habló de esa relación que hay entre el
cambio climático y la aparición de
pandemias como la que estamos viviendo
en este momento qué impresiones le deja
usted la finalización de esta cumbre lo
deja con un sinsabor con un poco de
incertidumbre porque no se trató este
tema a profundidad porque estamos más
expuestos que nunca a otro escenario
como el que vivimos desde hace un año
acá
estamos totalmente desconcertados porque
fueron pobres los resultados por las
conclusiones y por el impacto real la
disrupción del medio ambiente es un
factor determinante para la aparición de
las pandemias el cambio climático y la
facilidad de la adaptación de los
vectores para otro tipo de enfermedades
que se transmiten son fundamentales ya
no hay respuestas como humanidad fuertes
acerca del control del cambio de clima
claro que no es más es más protege no
tanto el cuidado puede ser pero a otras
infecciones que están desarrollando
estamos viendo como el dengue está
haciendo azotando la región de américa
central como hay más casos de dengue a
más altura como enfermedades permitidas
por vectores en otras partes del mundo y
eso es directamente relacionado con el
cambio climático yo recibí resumiría
santiago lo que usted dijo pobres
resultados pobres decisiones y muy pobre
sensibilidad hacia las infecciones y el
cambio del clima realmente estamos
desconcertados con lo que pasó
doctor pérez muchas gracias por
conversar con nosotros aquí en kobe 19
la semana en américa nos vemos la
próxima semana muchas gracias pues ya lo
decíamos en el avance en el sumario esta
semana eeuu también alivió algunas de
sus restricciones de viaje permitió el
ingreso de viajeros particularmente
procedentes de europa y de asia abrió
sus fronteras pese a que la vacunación
con el esquema completo solamente llega
al 58% de la población hay muchos
estadounidenses que no quieren vacunarse
veamos
eeuu acerca de la nueva normalidad
veinte meses después levantó las
restricciones a los viajes turísticos en
aeropuertos y fronteras terrestres los
turistas ya pueden ingresar al país con
un certificado de vacunación y una
prueba pcr negativa realizada máximo
tres días antes del embarque una medida
que hasta el momento no presenta una
incidencia de importancia y mucha
emoción básicamente libertad y solo la
oportunidad de ver a personas que no he
visto en mucho tiempo el austral vos te
imaginas mucha tristeza pero ya que
estadio ya estamos aquí por media para
comer tics de éste mcdonal's
según la asociación de viajes de estados
unidos el cierre de las fronteras por el
cob y 19 supuso la pérdida de 300 mil
millones de dólares de ingresos
contabilizables y la pérdida de un
millón de puestos de trabajos asociados
al sector de viajes y turismo algo que
se agudizó tras la obligación de
vacunarse propuesta de la casa blanca
los socorristas enfermeras pilotos
trabajadores cruciales están renunciando
porque no permitirán que se infrinjan
sus derechos nuestra economía tiene una
gran necesidad de trabajadores y la
decisión desesperada del presidente es
un paso atrás en las de este problema
sin embargo la corte federal de
apelaciones del quinto circuito
suspendió temporalmente el requisito de
la administración de seguridad y salud
ocupacional para que dichos trabajadores
se vacunen contra el cob y 19 a partir
del 4 de enero o deban usar mascarilla y
hacerse una prueba semanalmente mientras
que 27 de los 50 estados han impugnado
la orden esto a pesar de que según la
organización a wall world in that a más
de 46 millones de personas en una
población de más de 330 millones de
habitantes han contraído el virus en
esta nación la que más contagios ha
presentado en el mundo pues vamos
justamente a eeuu en donde hubo como ya
lo veíamos temas y anuncios importantes
a lo largo de esta semana vamos a
conectar con mamá en sala en la ciudad
de nueva york que mamen gracias por
acompañarnos hoy en el programa quiero
comenzar con un balance hagamos un
balance de lo que dicen las autoridades
de eeuu después de abrir las fronteras y
eliminar las restricciones de los vuelos
procedentes de europa
si aquí desde luego cada vez se escucha
más turistas internacionales en las
calles de la gran manzana y en general
en todo el país un motor económico el
turismo que hacía mucho tiempo que se
esperaba pero que aún así preocupa a los
expertos sanitarios porque no debemos
olvidar que en eeuu el proceso de
vacunación se encuentra estancado desde
hace varios meses con tan sólo un 58% de
la población completamente vacunado y
además en los últimos días hemos visto
un aumento de contagios en 29 de los 50
estados así que mucha emoción por esa
apertura de fronteras pero también con
se mira como decía con preocupación los
turistas poco a poco se están
acostumbrando a las nuevas reglas de
visitar lugares tan turísticos como un
nueva york por ejemplo pues en la
mayoría de los establecimientos no se
requiere la mascarilla siempre que estén
vacunados pero sí que se les va a pedir
esa prueba de vacunación en la mayoría
de los comercios y establecimientos de
atracciones turísticas eso sí hemos
visto muchísima más gente por las calles
las mismas cadenas hoteleras nos cuentan
que han tenido un aumento de al menos un
30% más
y a la hora de conseguir la entrada para
las principales atracciones turísticas
pues en muchos casos nos encontramos con
varios días de espera así que bueno una
de las cosas que han tenido que tener en
cuenta los turistas es que para entrar
al país hace falta demostrar que se ha
recibido las dos dosis en el caso de
todas las vacunas - johnson and johnson
que es una sola dosis 14 días antes de
entrar al país muchos europeos el
problema que están teniendo es que
aquellos que ya han tenido el joven en
europa se les está permitiendo recibir
una sola dosis de la vacuna pues bien
aquí no sería suficiente para poder
entrar al país amén usted lo mencionaba
la vacunación está estancada y la
respuesta del gobierno federal ha sido
la obligatoriedad y esto ha generado
controversias y en eeuu varios estados
se han negado en poner esta ley en su
territorio y también a nivel empresarial
no ha gustado mucho tener que obligar a
los empleados a vacunarse que dicen allí
en eeuu sobre este tema
si es una problemática que vemos en todo
el país esta semana sin ir más lejos la
corte suprema- de maine acaba de
rechazar las exenciones religiosas para
evitar la vacunación en el personal
sanitario aquí en nueva york ya ha
comenzado esa obligatoriedad de
vacunarse entre los trabajadores
municipales y ha provocado que cerca de
26 mil empleados del gobierno estén
suspendidos de sueldo porque se niegan a
vacunarse al movimiento en algunas zonas
del país es bastante fuerte y eso
preocupa a los expertos sanitarios
porque no se podrá llegar a alcanzar esa
inmunidad de grupos recordemos como
decía antes que aquí de momento sólo hay
un 58 por ciento de la población
completamente bajo nada es decir que
haya recibido las dos dosis a esto se
suman también pues protestas en todo el
país y sobre todo muchas demandas en la
corte suprema- por parte de los estados
más republicanos que se niegan a
vacunarse alegando mi cuerpo yo he
decidido así que como podéis ver este
tema es algo que tiene muy dividido
profundamente dividido al país
bien seguimos hablando de la vacunación
hablemos de ese buen inicio de acuerdo a
lo que dice el gobierno federal de la
vacunación en los menores de edad cuál
es el balance hecho a lo largo de esta
semana que dicen allí
si la campaña de vacunación entre niños
de 5 y 11 años se está llevando a muy
buen ritmo como se esperaba hasta el
momento 900.000 niños en todo el país ya
han recibido al menos una dosis hay
cerca de 200.000 farmacias consultorios
y espacios clínicos donde se pueden
administrar esas vacunas y se espera que
se administre a 28 millones de niños de
entre 5 y 11 años que son los elegibles
se lleva muy buen ritmo y se teme que se
pueda ver frenado así que desde la
administración se insiste a las escuelas
que den todo tipo de facilidades que
habiliten centros para poder a vacunar a
los niños lo antes posible con la vista
puesta ya en las celebraciones del día
de acción de gracias y de navidades
cuando se espera que las familias se
junten y cuantos más miembros de esa
familia estén valorados pues más seguro
será para todos va a haber muchas
gracias por este completo reporte desde
la ciudad de nueva york- mamen sala y
formándonos dando los detalles de la
situación allí en estados unidos- y pese
a no tener una aprobación de la
organización mundial de la salud la oms
las vacunas cubanas han comenzado a ser
vendidas en diferentes países veamos por
ejemplo venezuela ya ha recibido varios
lotes de estas vacunas lo mismo que
nicaragua y también la república
islámica de irán vietnam también en el
sudeste asiático ya ha recibido algunas
vacunas cubanas y por supuesto pues la
misma isla cuba que es la que lo ha
desarrollado
y precisamente el pasado mes de agosto
la isla de cuba hacía frente a uno de
los peores momentos de la crisis
sanitaria desde que comenzó la pandemia
ahora la situación ha cambiado por
completo y el país presenta una fuerte
reducción de casos de contagio gracias a
un rápido plan de vacunación que tiene
como base precisamente las vacunas que
fueron desarrolladas localmente con las
que han inoculado a diferentes segmentos
de la sociedad cubana adriana villacorta
nos cuenta más
una producción a gran escala el nuevo
complejo industrial biotecnológico de
mariel en cuba empezará a producir en la
quincena de diciembre vacunas y
medicamentos contra el cob y 19 el
objetivo es fabricar una línea de 12
bulbos de inmunizantes por hora y 30
millones de dosis en un plazo de 6 meses
aunque la planta también producirá otros
fármacos
la razón de esta
zona
según la organización a world in that a
la nación caribeña que cuenta con tres
vacunas nacionales abdalá soberana 2 y
soberana plus ya inoculó con el esquema
completo al 69 por ciento de su
población total que cuenta con más de 11
millones de personas
esto se ha visto reflejado en una
tendencia a la baja de contagios por
kobe 19 en la última semana se han
producido menos de 600 casos diarios en
efectos 612 mil alumnos de sexto a
onceavo grado regresaron a las aulas
después de largos meses
nosotros confiamos las vacunas que ya la
mayoría de nuestros niños tienen las 32
sexto grado tiene las tres dosis
puesta y esperamos que
que no que no que no ocurra que no
ocurra porque hasta ahora ninguno de
nuestros pioneros acá en esta escuela se
nos ha infectado con lakovic
además los viajeros internacionales ya
no tienen que someterse a una cuarentena
obligatoria al ingresar al país tampoco
tendrán que presentar una prueba pcr
negativa o realizarla a su llegada
aunque deberán portar un pasaporte de
salud con vacunas certificadas por las
agencias reguladoras
sin embargo los fármacos cubanos contra
el coronavirus aún no han sido aprobados
por la o ms
veamos a continuación cómo está
avanzando la vacunación en el continente
americano les presentamos el porcentaje
de la población con un esquema completo
y con una dosis demos un vistazo a las
cifras de brasil allí con el 59% de la
población ya tienen el esquema completo
de vacunación con una sola dosis sólo el
17% la isla de barbados en el caribe el
46% de la población ya tiene el esquema
completo el 7% solo una dosis surinam de
vuelta en américa del sur 35 por ciento
de la población con todo el esquema 7.5
con una sola dosis paraguaya alcanzó ya
al 33% de la población con el esquema
completo el 76 por ciento de la
población tiene sólo una dosis guatemala
alcanzó el 19 por ciento de la población
con un esquema completo y con una sola
dosis solamente el 11 por ciento
y en venezuela los contagios y
fallecidos siguen en aumento al menos
así es el sentir de los ciudadanos pero
para las autoridades cerca del 70% de
los venezolanos ya fueron inoculados con
diferentes tipos de vacunas contra el
cob y 19 entre ellas las vacunas
desarrolladas en cuba para cálculos de
la hoy ps la cifra no supera el 32 25
por ciento de la población el informe es
de ariana villacorta
datos contradictorios según la
organización war in dará en la última
semana se han producido entre 600 y 1000
contagios diarios por kobe 19 en
venezuela un número que no ha variado
mucho desde febrero a pesar de que
nicolás maduró el presidente de esta
nación asegura que el 70 por ciento de
la población venezolana ya fue
inmunizada
buenas noticias venezuela llegó al 70
por ciento de su población vacunada y
desde mañana el lunes 8 de noviembre
comenzamos con la inmunización de los
niños y niñas mayores de 2 años estamos
creando las condiciones óptimas para
tener un fin de año y unas navidades
felices sin embargo la organización
panamericana de la salud indica que en
el país sudamericano se han aplicado
poco más de 23 millones de dosis de la
vacuna contra el coronavirus esto quiere
decir que sólo el 32 3% de su población
total que cuenta con más de 28 millones
de habitantes habría recibió el esquema
completo de la vacuna contra el cubit 19
entretanto empezó la vacunación para
niños a partir de los 2 años bueno
estamos vacunando en este momento en
toda la región capital como bien dije
empezando con niños de 2 a 11 años que
puedan tener algún tipo de discapacidad
inmunológica que puedan tener
debilitamiento de su sistema
inmunológico por ejemplo niños con
alguna enfermedad renal algún tipo de
enfermedad que comprometa a su sistema
inmunológico lo estamos atendiendo de
forma prioritaria
los niños reciben la vacuna cubana
soberana 2 y se prevee se autoriza en
los próximos días el uso de la vacuna
apta la esta semana cuba envió un lote
de más de 16 millones de dosis de este
fármaco a venezuela la academia nacional
de medicina de este país rechaza la
insistencia que considera que tiene el
gobierno en vacunar a los niños más aún
con las vacunas que no han sido
aprobadas por los organismos
internacionales
y el director de la organización mundial
para la salud de dro saddam hombre jesús
alertó sobre el aumento de casos de
contagio de kobe 19 tanto en países que
tienen altas tasas de vacunación como en
países que tienen bajas tasas de
vacunación debido a que las vacunas
reducen el riesgo de hospitalización y
de muerte pero no previene la
transmisión del virus o de el
coronavirus en este caso lo que los
llevó a hacer nuevamente un llamado al
autocuidado y también a tomar medidas
preventivas sobre todo hizo un llamado a
los gobiernos a escuchemos bucks
instruidos de reese las vacunas reducen
el riesgo de hospitalización
enfermedades graves y muerte pero no
previenen completamente la transmisión
juli broadbent transmisión we con chili
tour y comen de tyler seguimos
recomendando el uso personalizado y
proporcionado de prueba máscara
distanciamiento físico medidas para
prevenir el hacinamiento mejorar la
ventilación y vacunarse cuando sea su
turno en get vaccinated benítez
georgetown countries wheat digest boxing
cover it con chin u2 stockpile more
boxing los países con la mayor cobertura
de vacunas continúan almacenando más
vacunas mientras que los países de bajos
ingresos continúan esperando todos los
días se administra en seis veces más
refuerzos a nivel mundial que las dosis
primarias en los países de bajos
ingresos este es un escándalo que debe
terminar ahora
this is a scandal that + stop now y es
que ya lo hemos dicho la pandemia no ha
terminado pese a que en muchos países
los casos han disminuido en otros ya
está empezando a aumentar la región de
américa latina y especialmente de
américa del sur estamos atravesando por
un buen momento los números han bajado
pero hay algunos países donde los
indicadores han comenzado a generar
preocupación los casos están a la baja
en la mayoría de la región la vacunación
está en aumento pero hasta cuando eso no
lo sabremos cuándo se va a revertir la
moneda y la situación en la que estamos
ahora nosotros que es completamente lo
contrario a lo que se está presentando
en europa en este momento veamos las
cifras para hacer una comparación entre
las dos regiones entre américa del sur y
europa para el 16 de junio del 2021
américa del sur reportaba 330 punto 36
casos de contagio por millón de
habitantes estábamos en uno de los picos
más difíciles
ese momento en la mitad del año que es
uno de los peores momentos que hemos
registrado en la región mientras que las
cifras para el 11 de noviembre es decir
hace pocas horas hace pocos días es
decir 5 meses después de la primera
cifra que les presente estamos
reportando
45.61 casos por millón de habitantes
ahora veamos cómo está en europa todo lo
contrario miren las cifras del 'viejo
continente' para el 17 de junio del 2021
cuando américa del sur estaba en ese
pico mortal de contagio europa tenía
números que rodeaban los 52 puntos 25
casos por millón de habitantes cinco
meses después ahora que américa del sur
está en un momento de caída de casos
europa está repuntando
360 punto 89 casos por millón de
habitantes totalmente lo opuesto a lo
que estamos viviendo en nuestra región
eso nos sirve de espejo
precisamente preocupa a los expertos lo
que está pasando en el 'viejo
continente' estos aumentos de los casos
algunos países están presentando récords
de contagios aumento de fallecidos
algunos países como letonia tuvieron que
volver a un confinamiento nacional en
una campaña de celo cero tolerancia
contra el coronavirus lo que sucede allí
ya lo decía yo no sirve como espejo para
la región de américa latina- si no
tomamos medidas y no aumentamos la
vacunación podríamos estar viviendo lo
mismo en tan sólo unos meses veamos la
crisis sanitaria se vuelve a
intensificar en europa
recientemente el número de casos aumentó
en un 7% y el número de muertes en un
10% según un informe emitido por la
organización mundial de la salud entre
los países más afectados por la cuarta
ola en esta región están rusia reino
unido austria y alemania
fue una explosión masiva con las pruebas
de las últimas dos semanas supongo al
principio vimos un pequeño crecimiento y
luego lo anticipamos agregando otra
unidad para probar más y día a día se
convirtió en mucho mucho más ahora
empezamos el día con una agenda completa
mucha gente viene sin cita porque
quieren un examen con todas sus fuerzas
pero ya no tenemos plazas
en place
entretanto el gobierno de austria espera
que el parlamento dé el visto bueno para
confinar a quienes no están vacunados
mientras que rusia planea introducir el
pase sanitario de manera obligatoria
cuando fue contactado por france 24
ralph rangers epidemiólogo de la
universidad de ciencias aplicadas de
hamburgo explicó los motivos un tercio
de los adultos aún no están vacunados
los efectos de la vacuna empiezan a
desvanecerse luego de seis meses y la
variante delta que continúa
expandiéndose
la única forma en que podemos
resolverlos es con un tratado o acuerdo
vinculante entre naciones un pacto
forjado a partir del reconocimiento de
que no tenemos futuro sino un futuro
común con la salud de las personas y el
planeta en el centro algo que también ha
repercutido en eeuu y que podría
reflejarse en el resto del continente
americano donde hay países como uruguay
que ha inoculado con el esquema completo
a más del 75 por ciento de su población
total mientras hay otros como nicaragua
que no llegan ni al 10% según la
organización or world in their
bueno pues ya lo estamos diciendo aquí
en france24 lo estamos mencionando meses
atrás para que sirva de advertencia para
toda la región seguimos hablando de
alemania este país ha protagonizado esta
semana récords de contagio en europa
cifras de hasta 50 mil nuevos casos
contabilizados en sólo 24 horas las
autoridades están estudiando allí
restablecer algunas restricciones desde
berlín nuestro corresponsal toma sparrow
nos dan más detalles de lo que están
discutiendo las autoridades federales y
las autoridades de los diferentes
estados en torno a este tema escuchemos
fue una semana crítica una semana muy
difícil para alemania en su lucha contra
la cuarta ola de la pandemia el
coronavirus con cifras récord en el
número de infectados que incluso
superaron los 50 mil nuevos contagios en
24 horas crece la preocupación sobre lo
que todo esto pueda significar en las
próximas semanas sobre todo en cuanto a
la tasa de hospitalización y crece
también la presión de parte de los
ciudadanos para que las autoridades
tomen cartas en el asunto para que
impongan nuevas medidas nuevas
restricciones que ayuden a frenar esta
ola pero alemania se encuentra en un
limbo político importante que dificulta
precisamente la toma de decisiones con
el gobierno de angela merkel en
funciones de manera interina y con tres
partidos que están tratando de formar la
nueva coalición del gobierno y que ya
presentaron sus planes para luchar
contra la pandemia con una virus pero
que no pueden implementarlos pues aún no
están en el poder
tomás sparrow informándonos desde una
berlín muy otoñal ya y brevemente les
presentamos otras noticias de esta
semana en nuestro continente brevemente
les cuento que en el salvador recibieron
un nuevo lote de más de 205 mil dosis de
vacunas de la farmacéutica pfiezer para
mantener la alta tasa de vacunación que
tiene esta nación centroamericana
hablando también del aumento de casos
chiles vean por ejemplo este caso ya
reportó 2 mil 900 nuevos casos una de
las cifras que da evidencia del aumento
que está registrando este país
escalonadamente en las últimas semanas
estos casos fueron detectados después de
haber realizado 82 mil pruebas pcr a
nivel nacional y brevemente les cuento
que la ciudad de mexico la capital
mexicana permanecerá en semáforo verde y
se mantienen allí todo lo contrario de
la situación de chile las mínimas de
hospitalización y los casos de contagio
cifras ya históricas en ese país si las
comparamos con el desempeño que ha
tenido la pandemia de kobe 19 en la
capital mexicana
y ahora demos su vistazo a otras
noticias relacionadas con el cob y 19
destacadas en redes comenzamos con esta
publicación de eleconomista el
fabricante de pruebas de kobe 19 retira
2.2 millones de tests caseros
defectuosos que fueron enviados a eeuu
así lo informó la autoridad sanitaria de
los eeuu al detectar el mes pasado
fallos en algunos de estos tests que
reportaron 35 casos de 'falsos
positivos'
y esta publicaciones de el diario
elmundo austria impone un confinamiento
parcial para los no vacunados este país
del centro de europa se convertirá en
una sociedad a dos velocidades
diferentes así lo indica esta
publicación que señala que las regiones
de alta austria y salzburgo ya pusieron
en marcha este confinamiento pero a
nivel federal podría ser determinado por
el gobierno en viena en los próximos
días así lo dio a conocer el canciller
federal de austria alexander charlene
viaja
y para el cierre los dejamos con esta
noticia la ope s casos de kobe 19
aumentan en américa tras dos meses de
disminución se lo estamos volviendo a
mencionar ya esta es una realidad
evidente el repunte comienza en
cualquier momento carissa etienne la
directora de la ope se indicó que la
región reporta a 700 mil casos nuevos y
13.000 fallecimientos por semana el
conosur colombia algunos países del pp
del caribe también bolivia son algunos
de los estados donde están comenzando a
notarse aumentos de casos de contagio
y ya los comentábamos sobre la apertura
de las fronteras en eeuu que permitieron
el ingreso de miles de viajeros a este
país norteamericano esto dejó
enternecedoras y emocionantes escenas de
familiares amigos parejas y conocidos en
diferentes aeropuertos de ese país que
casi un año después de confinamiento y
restricciones por fin pudieron volver a
encontrarse y esto lleva a revivir ese
sentimiento de esperanza y de normalidad
hicimos esta recopilación de imágenes
para ustedes nuestra audiencia de france
es todo por esta semana aquí en kobe 19
la semana en américa ya saben hay que
seguir cuidándose lavándose las manos
usando el tapabocas y atendiendo a las
restricciones de cada uno de los
gobiernos de los países desde donde
ustedes sintonizan nuestra señal sigan
con nosotros hasta la próxima
[Música]